millions of Muslims are heading to Mecca
right now you've seen the photos you've
seen the videos you've even seen the
snaps but why are they going well it's
hash the Hajj pilgrimage is one of the
five pillars of Islam a requirement for
every Muslim was physically and
financially able to take the trip to
Saudi Arabia at least once in their
lifetime it happens during the Islamic
month of dhul hijjah and takes place in
the holiest city for muslims neckla the
pilgrimage commemorates the story of
Abraham who Muslims believe was
commanded by God to build the Kaaba as a
representation of his house on earth the
hedge involves performing several
rituals over the course of three days
that includes circling the Kaaba and
iconic scene from has you've probably
seen lots of pictures of when the hedges
complete pilgrims and their trip by
visiting Medina referred to as the city
of the Prophet Muhammad meanwhile the
rest of the Muslim world is celebrating
the biggest Muslim holiday Eid al-adha
not the Ramadan Eid that's why the food
that the hedges believed to be the most
important spiritual journey a Muslim
will take but it's pricey the hedge
package for an American pilgrim for
example includes transportation food and
lodging and could cost anywhere from
five thousand to sixteen thousand
dollars per person some pilgrims spend
their whole lives saving for the basic
package for others it's a more luxurious
experience over the last decade Saudi
Arabia has spent billions modernizing
the holy city and the hajj itself in
Mecca you'll not only find 5-star hotels
but also high-end shopping and gourmet
dining and it's paying off
in 2014 the government earned an
estimated nineteen billion dollars in
revenue from the hedge Saudi Arabia also
maintains sole control over how many
pilgrims get to do the hedge from each
country and I mean some countries get to
send fewer pilgrims for reasons ranging
from political disagreements to health
concerns but another reason behind a
quota is to limit overcrowding that can
lead to dangerous situations like
stampedes despite the Saudi government
introducing measures to improve security
and crowd control stampedes have been a
major problem 2015 was the deadliest
hygiene reason
Saudi Arabia estimates that nearly 800
people died in the crush other estimates
say the death toll was closer to 2000
but stampedes and expenses aside
millions of Muslims will continue to
visit Mecca every year and the Hajj will
go on